this is my wine now sorry guys hi I'm
Hannah Hart and I am a youtuber today I
want to show you guys how to make the
taco potato this recipe comes from one
of my favorite episodes of my drunk
kitchen one night filmed with a good
friend of mine Tyler Oakley it kind of
began when I saw somebody who had taken
taco ingredients and put them on top of
a diced baked potato and then I thought
why not make it handheld and portable
which is just a wonderful aspect of all
food communities is that you can relate
and inspire each other to try new things
in the kitchen my most recent kitchen
memory stems from having gone to a
Motown music dance night with all my
friends and then I invited everybody
over and I made them a delicious
spaghetti Atta which is just a giant
bowl of pasta and that's kind of the
best way to end the night I love feeding
people and having everybody feel fed my
relationship with food has always been
one of enthusiasm not expertise food
allows for a lot of freedom if you let
it I love adding citrus I'm a big citrus
person I love lemon I love onion I love
spice so I try and incorporate a little
lemon onion or spice into everything I
do you can figure out what flavor
combinations you really love and then
just start sticking it and stuff I am
the type of person who at a party loves
to go and hang out in the kitchen and
just have a conversations with people I
think the kitchen is really a communal
space that allows for everybody to just
kind of relax and be themselves Oh
I really love the look on somebody's
face when you give them something you
made and they're like whoa this is good
and I'm like great